welcome and happy sabbath everyone to
question and answer with elder randy skeets
sorry about that happy sabbath again and
welcome to question and answer with elder
randy skeet on the word inspired i'm your host
denise mccurchion and i'm joined by special guests
elder randy skeet sister alana kwashi sister
joanna smith and sister shirelle pierre and
today we will be discussing the resurrection and
answering questions like what is the resurrection
what is its purpose what will be the body
of the righteous when they are resurrected
do we have hope after death stay tuned as
we seek to answer these questions by god's
grace and be generous with the word like share
and subscribe and we pray that you are blessed
as we seek to ascertain this fundamental belief
of the bible let us pray dear heavenly father we
thank you for this opportunity to learn of
you we ask that you forgive us of our sins
and we welcome your presence in our midst please
direct the proceedings of this program and we ask
the lord that you would receive the honor the
glory and the praise in jesus name we pray amen
all right so we are moving right along today
we are joined by international speaker elder
randy skeet he is a husband and a humble man
of god he's a graduate of oakwood university
and also of the seventh-day adventist theological
seminary at andrews university where he studied
for the ministry as he would say i ask that you
pray that god will put his words in his mouth
let's listen be reverent and think as he
speaks please welcome elder randy skeet
thank you very much dr denisha it's always my
pleasure to join you in these programs which i
value very highly i think they serve a very very
significant role and so i am delighted to be here
and i pray that the spirit of god will
direct my remark so that those who listen
will be blessed by the truth it is the truth alone
that makes a person free according to john 8 32
and in verse 36 it is christ that makes you free
so at the highest level truth is christ and so my
intention is to deliver thus saith the lord
and hope that someone listening will be blessed
particularly if there's someone listening who's
not a seventh adventist i am very glad that you're
with us and may the lord enlighten your mind to
a degree that brings you closer and closer to him
and may god bless all those associated with this
program i'm ready to answer the questions as the
spirit directs amen thank you for that prelude
elder skeet the first question you know we we
like to put them together it has two parts the
first part is what is the resurrection and the
second part is what is its purpose all right i
need to pray i didn't do that father in heaven
as i respond to questions from your people give me
wisdom it is promised in james chapter one verse
five if any of you lack wisdom let him ask of god
i ask you now not for my sake but for the sake of
those whom you love who are listening that your
name may be glorified in the truth and their lives
blessed in jesus name i pray amen the resurrection
is that glorious event where the dead shall return
from the grave uh two kinds will return the
just and the end just for two different reasons
the just to live with christ forever the unjust
to see why they are lost why they will be punished
and then to receive the due punishment and so we
have the resurrection mentioned in daniel chapter
12 verse 2 and many of them that sleep in the dust
of the earth shall away some to everlasting life
some to share an everlasting damnation we have
resurrection mentioned in john 5 28 marvel not
at this that the hour is coming in the which all
that in the grier shall hear his voice and shall
come forth they that have done good under the
resurrection of life they have done evil under the
resurrection of damnation this is christ we have
it in first uh thessalonians 4 16 for the lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a shout
with the voice of the archangel and with the trump
of god and the dead in christ shall rise first
of course first corinthians 15 is fully dedicated
to the concept of the resurrection and so it is a
fundamental teaching of the bible because without
the resurrection there is no gospel because the
purpose of the gospel is to restore things as
they were before adam's sin there was no death
before adam saying there must be a resurrection
so that those who have given their lives to christ
can enjoy that endless life with him john 3 16
says for god soul loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son that whosoever believeth
in him should not perish but have everlasting
life in order to have that everlasting life
people must be ransomed from the grave through
the blood of christ and so the resurrection is
the coming up out of the grave two kinds of
people the first in the first resurrection
to live with christ the second to receive the
punishment and uh so that's the resurrection and
when it will happen thank you so much elder screen
and you know this is so key that you mentioned how
interconnected the resurrection is with the
hope of the christian because our foundation
is built on the fact that jesus lives if jesus
did not resurrect then our preaching is in vain
our faith is in gain we have no hope but
thank god for the hope and the power of
the resurrection that we have in jesus there's a
reason why christ had there must be a resurrection
god promised abraham for instance in genesis
chapter 13 verse 14 the bible says and god
said unto abram after that lot was separated from
him lift up now then eyes and look from the place
with our northward and southward and eastward and
westward for all the land which now see us to thee
will i give it and to thy seed forever that's what
he promised him in verse 17 he tells abraham arise
walk through the land to the length of it and
the breath of it for i will give it unto thee
and it is repeated in chapter 15 it's repeated
in 17 god would give abraham the land and his
seed but hebrews 11 13 tells us these all died in
faith not having received the promises but having
seen them afar off and were persuaded of them
and embraced them so abraham isaac and jacob
the three get great patriarchs with whom god is
closely associated because he's god of abraham
isaac and jacob they did not receive the land
literally in their lives they died as strangers
in the land where they lived god must come back
to fulfill his promise to abraham also when god
told abraham lift up now then eyes and look from
the place with our northward and southward and
eastward and westward that was a reference to
the entire world it was the time when lot had
chosen the fertile planes around sodor and
left the rough area in the hills for abraham
god brief showing abraham the day will
come when you will receive the entire world
and paul makes this absolutely clear in romans 4
13 where he said and the promise that he should
be the heir of the world was not to abraham
through the law but by the righteousness of
faith and so when god promised abraham the land
he promised him the whole world there were two
levels of fulfillment the israelites did come
in and possess the land but on a wider scale
it will be given to the meat who shall inherit
the earth and those are the ones who have given
their lives to christ and so god must come back to
keep his promise to abraham because the bible says
in titus chapter 1 verse 2 god cannot lie and
in numbers 23 19 he does not lie he must come
back he must resurrect abraham and his seed and
his seed refers to anyone who's accepted christ
he must come back resurrect them and finally
keep his word fully there must be a resurrection